already a lot of food production is
automated we have big machines doing
most of the work two do you ever you
ever hear the phrase fully automated
luxury communism
that's exactly what people are looking
for so not only is what we're talking
about definitely on the horizon there
are people that are excited for it to
arrive and want to do everything they
can to expedite its arrival fully
automated luxury communism there are
people that don't want to do anything
other than be plugged into the Matrix
and be ha and and be pumped full of the
feel-good drugs because existence itself
leads to suffering so that's because
that's the truth this is where I mean we
talk about having a mental health crisis
in the country or across the globe is
this what happens then the next step is
to make everybody feel better by having
a fake world
well
people are going to choose it